six the screen head 23.8 god who's hit
the last three wide open young that's
seven for dick that's way out in front
number one in the league in attendance
Jason Terry is on the floor as well
three ball is good for Nick Young while
Nick Young can score the three ball
that's right talk about the relationship
side of it starts with our owner he had
the vision to make his sin the home of
all our great legs did you see it from
there after four games the regular
season can you win a championship
playing this way well we don't know that
until they do it extremely difficult
rebound Crowder
Moriah Jefferson George Chandler Crowder
that's the rest of the lineup this
Jefferson blocked out of bounds by Nick
Young gonna be Lakers give up the most
free throws per game of anybody in the
league so a couple there by Janet young
count it foul that's good to see Nick
hitting his first shot of the night and
they shoot the fewest threes a game 14.9
on average young inside outside
everybody having some who's know all
about him so they're planning for him
now not a surprise that he was last year
when he was a rookie out of Louisville
look at young Brides in you throwing it
down as he goes baseline and all of a
sudden on the year this is just what
they needed
don't Nick young hope he found him don't
even give that thing all the way in the
direction of the hoop so those shots are
coming off a little hard and a little
off in the rim Nick Young fouled on the
shot isn't about to return and go one
starter in the game it's young against
Casey Dean's back up fake that's what
scorers do make sure you have defensive
balance so the guys don't just run out
like that
seven four-point plays last he brings up
two and three to shoot
now young
[Applause]
young sex
[Music]
denied Oh
[Music]
looking for the whistle I just don't
know how you make that shot because he
never really has good follow-through
he's his body's comported
[Applause]
just trying to get there another steal
by price won't get it
Boozer fighting
[Music]
they're on their way long as the same
trip going through the shot dr. Jerry
board it's just so nice but if it's
bolder with it five against Dallas on to
pick you up please the last game this
young attack can post you up and also
can step out in 18 feet knock down shots
Nick Young this was going down
three-point opportunity for Nick Young
with West front and fires
[Music]
Judy for the Lakers we're 74 circus shot
for swaggy babe here cuz he can get his
own shot he dribbles that one off his
foot into the backcourt should be blazed
her ball no they're going to say it was
off the hook on shot clock at two
thought that was off the young he tries
the three and hits it take shots out of
your officers you don't hurry and help
the Lakers and the Lakers same way taken
score Nick Young scores be spent with
the toon gotta mommy are the [ __ ] he was
Nicky or beating father Tom averaging 27
points a game
and finally gets into the store book
that we may guess they're often after me
young
Nick Young against a water basketball
yes son
Lakers of God try the last
three-and-a-half you saw up by five
young once three got it boys silky
smooth it's time to get the ball out of
his hands we've seen this at some point
you got to concede allowed him to post
up it's not a guy who's gonna devastate
me with his back to the basket turn
around
[Applause]
[Applause]
unbelievable shot you have the bathroom
look at the contact here down low I mean
that is falling down to your left and
shooting back to your right on what
concentration there by Nick Young to
finish this potential four point play he
got his late man here comes Johnson the
other way and the one thing I forgot to
talk about we mentioned him a little bit
because we usually as Nick Young scores
on his foul
we cleaned up talking about Hughes when
we talked about the Blazer big final
seconds and it will be young from 40
swaggy P is back in the house at Staples
Center big-time finish by swaggy P
tremendous finish to the opening quarter
for the Lakers 821 5 run on opening
night swaggy P knocks down the three it
beats the buzzer from last year on this
Kings team it's a brand new bench for
them and a much better one also Nick
Young that'll count which confronts
Koufos for three the clock tonight what
they isn't and they'll head to the
second with the Lakers down
40:24 calling it an offensive rebound
for tark black that's the first
offensive rebound of the game for the
Lakeland it for three downtown yes sir
Nick Young and he glides I was well tied
Huertas quarter
Vick young give Marcello Huertas lurches
finds Nicky young in the corner and Nick
knocks down his second triple of the
content being defended by Larry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the corner drive and kick and Nic fires
right before the horn sounds then counts
isso warhead to the fourth with the
Lakers down by eight gives it off to
Williams I think he knows that soon as
he sits down it's going to tighten up
dick young yes sir you never look how
deep three pointer was from young no
question a little bit of trouble that
Nick Young is going to come up with the
steal here comes where it's three on two
Marcelo
back for Nick young hesitate first
quarter is now a 19 point lead yeah
that's a nightmare right now there's
young his 16 footer and finally the
Lakers are back on the board
think about it you've got five storey
championships right there for four Duran
and one for West
that's crazy deep young could certainly
light it up difficult away from all
including tonight five the next seven
away from Staples Center this point of
his work year here's McConnell kicked it
off with three right into the hand of
Nick Young and he's wearing the
Hollywood Knights black Rambo runs the
floor throw it down with the slam to
within two thanks to the three-pointer
by swaggy P they'll bounce it right side
Miller good law but earning poorly be
just under the red and Sabah's couldn't
finish it
Andre Miller feel one of the better
pastures for logs the way they
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh Nick Young gets the you're welcome
and the steel look to attack for
repacked on bottom while Nick backs up
and shoots a really good better and move
by the shooter Nick Young now poised for
beings especially throw an attack with
aggression
it's a two on two now it's a
four-on-three trailer Williams got the
triple Randall's got his second rebound
rebounds are even right now let's look
out below
nice play by Nick Young and then julius
finishing at me nobody wants to get
dunked on so everybody run for cover
twentieth point of the content in 20
minutes the point a minute guy Blaine
remember a couple years ago get about a
head full of those green the ball
handling between alleles
[Applause]
nicely by young Randall drives and
finishes it again we said it a few times
Arnie hits downhill mines capella he got
it back for the rockets hit possession
back deny so you played you print your
manboobs play my tank and his dream job
coaching the Lakers all day we mentioned
what a great team effort it was the
other night Russell
[Applause]
from downtown weather lingers went to
get Mozgov this size at his
shot-blocking to protect that RIM young
hito beginning for the Laker tied a
career-high with fetuses and Wednesday's
win against Atlanta nice custom time
[Applause]
with his newfound defensive energy he's
no longer swaggy P he's uncle P now one
of the senior statesmen on this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
opportunity here the Angelo just grabs
the ball away from Warren and then gets
the assist water play puts the Lakers up
99 92
brilliant Azure together gotta finish
the plane or weather point get a point
game don't be first of all this building
is real so it's great to be in here for
the Sacramento Kings but the instability
is real as we see Mozgov get on the
board first to load up this
great-looking place the run is still 67
Mozgov makes sure this time as Nick
Young finds up soon he will spin and
give it back to Julius where he just hit
a moment ago how is gonna give him that
John if he wants it it's gonna dry us
right but be a for as he's trying to
fight through the screen momentum
carries him right into the arm after he
caught the ball it'll push three on two
Nick Young all the way to store a little
contact and then he just threw in the
little short jump shot they lead by two
young good time but he's got to go
forward with green with two he'll get a
good look
[Applause]
in an operational zone he's going
Eastern web auto swear those shoulders
up north and south where a bail
three-pointer to end a half that's some
play by Nikhil which means the Lakers
have the lead this is my time is up
knocking down comes up way short
[Applause]
[Applause]
DeMarcus he tried to bounce it to
Collison so I'll turn over there and
it's going to be taken by the Lakers the
long day now to Montgomery running it
storm moved here recently lock it away
without provides guard after Jake mr.
fair
[Applause]
that angle past steal assists Lakers by
three in a Laker team that has lost
eight straight but right now the six is
looking like the struggling team that's
Randall running the floor and securing
to Julius Randle so he's better off the
girls and just catching situations hope
Nick Young he knows gonna find that one
and out it goes
another three for Nick Young
of course score that gets the assist on
the perimeter from Jordan Clarkson step
back for Clarkson Nick Young parts of
rope a good job by Nick Young goes up
just Hanks arrogance come on time for
Mark Williams three-point opportunity
had be back-to-back triples one
you weigh it and basically with Luke
Justine as well as we're not gonna win
on a steady diet him Mozgov is going to
be our leading scorer swaggy P with the
potential four-point play against
Charlotte Tuesday he had five as a foul
he drills one of the skip to Redick
[Applause]
was intended for Mozgov grapplers hat it
was beautiful
Nick's gonna pick the pocket of Carole
another look at that play I was just
talking about our Nick they turned it
over but all of a sudden Nicky's right
back in it defensively picks up the
steal and the basket that's Detroit
turned it over they commit the fewest
turnovers in the entire league with dogs
heap it down you got it many skips to
the other side of the floor I know I
didn't get down stream late you're only
as good as your last shot Nick Young
right now mudiay is pretty good with the
basketball very nice job was running the
fast-break Nick Young's got it it's a
good job to get it but then just hang on
to defense you think you're beat
[Applause]
and tonight as the knick taking
advantage of a shorter defender scores
easily
[Applause]
[Music]
spring Nick Young open over jaylen Brown
banks it home
oh it's swaggy P time early here are you
didn't Boston they have just taken the
nosedive but now they have also lost re
get into his body but going against the
shot clock too much turnovers really
kill the Lakers the other night he'll
get a four-point opportunity to Danny
Green open Lakers fortunate hookup yeah
there is Nick Young he broke out the
Brando found him and he dumps it on your
first look on a rebound is up visually
is up the floor first want to talk it
over they've given up an easy baskets at
the Lakers they're not used to seeing
that happen
seven plus rebounds seven consecutive
games
with a forward defense to offense
[Applause]
turnovers first both teams don't they
that's the 12th for the pelicans Lakers
down by 7 Troy and Miami and the Bulls
are lingering just a game and a half
back to start the game after the o49
against Houston a couple of nights ago
being under 30 percent since joining the
starting lineup 16 games ago all the way
to the basket said their community see
everybody thinking shooting outside he
came back with Jabari Parker went out
for the year a jump he's attacking the
rim it I mean that topic gets thought
maker really the surprised players maker
thinks he's gonna lay it up exists he'll
lay it up alright